preda a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fan i j
oggi andiamo avanti con bugs bunny
eravamo rimasti che avevamo sbloccato
l'era dei pirati e avevo appena finito
l'air ha praticamente quella preistorica
mi pare finito ovviamente tra virgolette
nel senso che ho battuto il primo boss
ok ragazzi siamo parte del filmato
iniziale ovviamente come in ogni era di
bugs bunny quando iniziamo un nuovo
livello e il primo livello dell'era
parte rimando il successo deficiente che
sinceramente non ricordo come si chiama
io raga il bossi me li ricordo
praticamente in tutti ma non mi ricordo
neanche il nome di uno a malapena mi
ricordo che battipanni si chiama bugs
bunny comunque va beh questo è il boss
che andremo a battere in questo livello
alla fine quindi raga siamo partiti
devo riuscire ad arrivare alla fine di
questo livello per sfidare il tizio con
la barba rossa di prima e niente
batterlo però sinceramente non so se
basta per sbloccarsi cos'è questo ho
distrutto una scatola rossa mi ricordo
che c'erano ma non ho mai capito che
cazzo servisse come non ho mai capito se
si cosi sono dentro anch'io delle rane
c'è vabbè si sono dei granchi per una
piccolo c'è dato che erano verdi li
scambiano per rane o chissà cosa non me
la ricordo
l'aspetto sono riuscito a fare passare
il ponte ea ok questa qua praticamente
devo riuscire a trovare la sveglia ok
vediamo se il mio cervello riesce a
seguire una minchia di paura ok
ok bene forse ho capito la gabor se ho
capito dovrebbe essere questa si ok bene
come primo tentativo andato abbastanza
bene da piccolo ci provavo a 20 volte
perché c'è a me veniva da guardare
dov'era pirata e poi dimenticavo della
sveglia va bene ok
sinceramente ragazzo gay devo riuscire
arrivare là sopra perfetto non mi
ricordo precisamente la strada per
arrivare dal tizio con la barba rossa
però ha dato che la strada una sola
direi di proseguire dico anche perché
non c'è altra via merda mi stanno
uccidendo even perfetto è ok raga questo
me lo ricordo era tipo
la donna me lo ricordo ancora devo
riuscire a prendere il sellino perfetto
che cazzo è successo devo riuscire a
prendere la perla ragazze miccoli ok
perfetto ed eva lanciarla nel bersaglio
che vediamo se riesco ce l'ho fatta se
sbagliamo questa ragazzo levate
deridermi in una maniera incredibile
ok ci siamo assieme a due ne manca una
se poi sinceramente raga io non mi
ricordo dopo che cosa c'è proverò a fare
di tutto ma ok merda che culo madonna
che salvataggi incredibile ok siamo bene
barile in faccia ai boss
devo riuscire a superare sul punto non
mi ricordo mesi fa
devo ok ci siamo recati camente devo
abbassare sti porti sinceramente non mi
ricordo proprio di preciso ma posso
essere pienamente di così
cioè non mi ricordo di preciso raga dove
portano sui costi
però so soltanto che alla fine di soli
vello cioè pirata quindi è alla fine ci
devo arrivare per forza
ok ok ok
ce l'ho fatta al primo tentativo raga
ma c'è anche una carota d'oro perfetto
devo riuscire
ok come faccia pre ha semplicemente
saltando giustamente sono un genio
no no no no no che culo che culo
sbagliato tasto e si sono invertiti
ragano non so perché adesso con r2
rotolo il contrario nell'altro episodio
non so perché devo farmi mica seguire
come un idiota fino a tirargli un calcio
nel culo di prepotenza non me lo ricordo
perfetto sera tu sei un bene uno snack
culo che è cool arte una sveglia non lo
ricordavo ragazzo è qui sotto se non
sbaglio c'è un passaggio segreto che
porta su un altro isolotto fa di fianco
boranga praticamente sto gioco l'ho
fatto io
no veramente addio di cazzo sono madonna
non me li ricordavo così tante
sinceramente va beh meno male
praticamente abbiamo tipo preso 5 carote
d'ore in una botta sola quindi va
benissimo
niente devo proseguire di qua perché
l'unica strada perfetto ragazze vi
ricordate tipo dei livelli o dei
trucchetti che io saldo poterlo sapere
perché non me lo ricordo ma lei mi ha
preso in pieno
devo riuscire a passare a di soprano
massi così non li prendo perché tanto
non mi pare che servissero chissà cosa
c'è se so completare merda il culo
dicevo stesso completare tutto al cento
per cento poi alla fine diventa anche un
po noioso quindi evito di farlo c'è al
completo proprio al massimo ebbene
allora devo tornare indietro ho sporcato
qualcosa
ok no semplicemente fatto merda ma
perché ma che sfiga
ok madonna che freestyler ce l'ho fatta
ok raga questo sinceramente non me lo
ricordo allora prendo sta roba non so
cosa mi serve ancora ma la prendo
mi pare che ci siano ok perfetto per
quanti contiene devo buttare giù 3 per
ci sono ci sono ma perché cazzo allora
il tasto no merda che cazzo è successo
mi ha mangiato maledetti da strada non
mi ricordavo il tasto con cui perfetto
raga un casino perché mi si sono
invertiti tipo i comandi adesso poi
vedrò bene nel prossimo episodio di
metterli a posto perché sennò un casino
beh ci siamo allora il prezzo e poi
possiamo arrivare in quell'isola che
sinceramente non mi ricordo che cosa ci
serve però di sicuro devo fare qualcosa
con sta roba quindi me la porto dietro
sì mi pare che devo fare merda ok no no
ok mi chiami sta salvando per miracolo
dai dai dai dai dai dai dai set appena
in tempo raga
fatemi tornare in tv non mi sento di
binario ok ci siamo se sono riuscito a
fare il suo livello per miracolo raga
bene direi di passare alla parte
successiva questa prima parte era anche
abbastanza facile quella dopo più o meno
me la ricordo però diciamo che un po più
incasinata del della parte di prima ok
gesso stronzo che mi lancia le bombe se
mi ricordo bene quelle che lampeggiano
devo evitarle subito invece quelle che
non lampeggiano tipo non questa con la
prossima se va bene ok questo glielo
devo rilanciare di quindi ecco se riesco
ok perfetto allora è bene perfetto
alzati brutto stronzo che non farò una
ok yes
ho dei ragazzi sia c'è uno squalo c'è un
[ __ ] squalo che non mi ricordavo che
ne faccio merda che cosa fa forse assi
forse devo distrarlo classi cosi con le
ossa credo
vabbè però sinceramente non sono anche
da che parte andare in questo momento
quindi avanti o indietro andiamo avanti
a sto punto dato che abbiamo fatto il
culo al pirata brutto stronzo prenditi
rosso ok
devo riuscire merda devo riuscire a
distrarlo con l'osso si infatti ci sono
riuscito e merda come non detto mi stava
beccando ok raga prosegue ci sono ancora
c'è l'invasione visti granchi rana
ok oddio ok ragazza mi stuprano di
violenza come faccio a prendere le
carote
ok forte no no no ok ragazzi sono di
nuovo devo riuscire a prendere tipo da
carrozza d'oro
ok forse vi è forse ho capito no se cioè
culo
devo riuscire porca [ __ ]
ok ragazzi sono di nuovo per l'ennesima
volta stavolta gioco di non fare figure
di merda ml stava sparando un'altra ma
ci sono riuscito ok ci siamo wingardium
leviosa sto sono in mezzo ai due barili
in teoria sarei dovuto a cadere in acqua
è rovinosamente ma sono riuscita a
salvarmi diciamo
ebbene st parte sinceramente oddio ok mi
seguono ma l'inizio ok ci ho fatto e
devo dar fuoco si codici non posso
semplicemente tirare un calcio al baule
come ho fatto fino adesso
ok perfetto il perfetto ci sono merda ok
[Musica]
ok
bene io mi ricordavo che sto pirata
potevi farlo fuori tranquillamente anche
fatto dando fuoco ai alle bombe
semplicemente così è infatti adesso ci
prova aspettate un attimo raga se mi
raggiunge ok come non detto non mi ha
raggiunto ma mi sono fatto male in
qualche modo stranissimo ok ci sono la
che ci sono manca l'ultimo raga ok è
questa qui
ebbene dai vedere che colpisco pirata
dai dai dai che ho fatto mi sono colpito
anche io come al solito non so perché il
pirata ancora in piedi non capisco come
cazzo faccia forse ragali ci vuole il
colpo di grazia aspettate un attimo che
prova a girare attorno alla palma se ok
s'è fermato perfetto
ok è caduto ok ha lasciato un timone si
è alzato un barile da qualche parte non
so dove ha lasciato tipo il timone che
devo mettere da qualche parte ma non mi
ricordo dove intanto vado al check point
air
perché se ci finisco secco devo rifare
praticamente da capo
ok devo riuscire a trovare il punto dove
mettere sto [ __ ] timone perché non ho
idea di dove debba metterlo sincera me
che l'ho trovato come non detto ok
perfetto questo è il passaggio che anche
sbloccato a che cosa mi serve sta roba
non lo so però non mezzo perfetto vai
apri apriti sesamo apri qualcosa
ok come al solito è un ponte ma non so
dove
a sto punto direi di contrae weeden co
sì ok ma se che cosa ha aperto la ga
sinceramente ok a questo qui è questo
qui per sono sicuro
ok c'è una merda concerti raga io sto
abbassando ponti a caso non so neanche
dove sono sti cosi kimi che c'è una
sveglia perfetto ok rai a rifarmi sic
merda merda mi stanno mi stuprano di
stupro mix markit è ok
posso levarmi dalle palle se non so bene
adesso raga che cosa ho sbloccato
sinceramente però devo passato un ponte
a caso non so quale è che ho tirato io
ho attirato l'osso idiota perché non vai
dall'osso ok merda siamo morti ragazzi
che cazzo sta facendo ok è
rispettivamente da di testa sto squalo
ma che fa
ok prova a lanciare un nostro spero che
lo distragga perché quello di prima non
è che ha funzionato tanto perfetto ok
raga mi sa che mi sono ricordato dov'era
il ponte è fuori forse è questo sia
questo qui ci arrivo si ci arrivo
perfetto
preparatevi che ci stiamo avvicinando
allo scontro con il boss asso punto raga
direi di proseguire
direi che ci siamo veramente avvicinando
al boss piano piano manca pochissimo è
praticamente qui dietro ragazzi siamo
devo riuscire soltanto a battere si trae
stronzi perché ce ne sono tre
ok allora spettate non mi ricordo me si
raccoglie ok tutto stronzo no è andato
un cazzo perché ce ne vogliono due mi
dimentico sempre raga per buttarlo giù
ce ne vogliono due perché se non ce la
faccio
[Musica]
bene adesso continuerà a lanciarmi bombe
perché esplodono subito perché non vuole
che io ce la faccia perfetto quante me
ne devi tirare ancora così
ah beh stiamo così noi dai incredibile
incredibile ce l'abbiamo fatta dopo due
ore a lanciare quelle bombe di merda né
lanciata una normale inquiline ma vero
il primo è andato raga ok manca il
secondo e poi anche il terzo ovviamente
nei lanci una normale ti prego grazie
ok lanciavano un altro regalino minchia
che generoso che sei altro che il tuo
amico di prima
ok ok ok ok merda imperfetto e anche
secondo è andato ma anche all'ultimo
non penso sia fine come quello di prima
invece sì invece si è ok perfetto ne
rimane a una radio e rimane un amico
cosa c'era qualcosa qui dietro esso non
mi ricordo sinceramente se ho lasciato
qualcosa alle spalle tipo dietro di me
no no no ok mettendo vista bomba qui
sinceramente non so che farmene assunto
la fiera in mare
ok ci siamo ragazzi amo per scontrarsi
contro il boss è anche al secondo
episodio di batman i son riuscito a
battere sempre che io riesca a batterlo
un boss del gioco perfetto e siamo già
due i due episodi
siamo partiti ragazza e lo stronzo nella
giu devo dire che questo come boss è
leggermente se mi ricordo bene se mi
ricordo bene leggermente più difficile
di quello di prima in quello dell
episodio scorso ovviamente pratica il
tasto prossimi impara chiede e io debba
lanciarci sisti cosi
finché non la massima definiscono mi si
raccoglie merda
ok primo è andato è la cosa che io non
ho mai capito nino borsa e che continua
a bombardarci con le palle di cannone
praticamente l'unico modo che noi
abbiamo per batterlo e lanciarli le pr
di allungato che un idiota cell e lancia
anche ovviamente in modo che noi
possiamo rilanciare le indietro e fargli
del male
oddio che cazzo succede i ragazzi si è
spento lo schermo merda che è successo
ok ci siamo di nuovo ci siamo di nuovo
non so che cosa è successo tipo si è
spento lo schermo non mi è mai successo
strana sta cosa si vede che è un
problema dell'emulatore vabbè mi hai
buttato giù una volta brutto stronzo
semplicemente perché lo schermo è dalla
tua parte
se non ci sarei riuscito ok stavo
dicendo appunto che
l'unico modo che abbiamo per button e
lancia l'idea queste cose e lui da genio
il quale c'e le lancia pure in modo che
noi possiamo rilanciare
stessa cosa infatti non come ca merda
merda merda merda merda merda merda
siamo due pari brutto stronzo
ok vista sinceramente da piccolo mi
facevo vuol dire neanche una volta si
vede che poi ho perso una mano e vabbè
non può non posso pretendere di essere
bravo come quando ero piccolo ok ci
siamo ragazzi mancano due dopo questa
una soltanto perfetto ci siamo ragazzi
siamo
non mi ricordo se questa pasta party
come noi infatti ne manca ancora una
perfetta
raga ancora una ce l'abbiamo fatta devo
scappare tipo che meriti il coyote
adesso
è una merda merda merda merda ok
perfetto ci ha presi ma sono ancora vivo
sono ancora vivo
ok ragazzi stiamo avere manca soltanto
una e poi lovato vai vai e vai lancia
mela il bravo piuttosto lanzo lancia
vela ma le ragazze stupisce veramente
quanto idiota perché si gira ogni volta
va bene giochiamoci lo spettacolo ora
che l'abbiamo battuto sia adesso tenterà
disperatamente di soffiare ma non ce la
farà beccati questo ok mi stavi sul culo
anche da piccolo ed ecco comparire pure
la sveglia ragazzi siamo abbiamo
completato livello battendo il bosso
anche nel secondo episodio non mi pare
che comunque queste basi che per
sbloccarsi la prossima era spesso che io
debba farmi qualche altro livello o qui
sempre nelle isole in generale oppure
nell'era dei della preistoria che c'è
merlo ottimo ma mai lasciato un genio
delle sue spalle
ok ragazzi sbloccato la roba dentro il
teschio che non mi ricordo che cos'è e
ho sbloccato anche l'era successiva non
me lo aspettavo sinceramente mi
ricordavo che dovevo fare altri livelli
in giro invece sono riuscito
miracolosamente a sbloccarmi anche l'era
successiva ok ci sono perfetto salvo la
partita così ci siamo
l'era successiva è quella dei dei
mafiosi però li vedremo nel prossimo
episodio
cos'è che ho sbloccato un livello di
dentro però non ci posso entrare perché
c'è sta roba qui che mi pare che si apra
con la roba che cieli sopra che però per
raggiungerla devo saltare con quella
fare l'iva è un casino raga praticamente
nel prossimo episodio
mi pare che fossero gli anni sessanta
come non detto gli anni trenta e in
pratica in se pisapia qui ci sono su due
ci sono due mafiosi che devo battere
[Musica]
molti di voi so che se vi ricorderanno
ma lo faremo soltanto nel prossimo
episodio per oggi direi che posso
chiudere qui sei video vi è piaciuto
come al solito lasciate un commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
non i video trovate nella descrizione mi
è caduto il telecomando fate finta di
niente se non siete ancora iscritti
iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo non
prossimo video bella ragazzi